salve come potete vedere solo
completamente sfatto sono lo yotobi
estivo con la cravatta tutta sfasciata
la camicia a mezze slabbrano un po
spettinato questo video perché beh
perché sono contento di dirvi che la
prima stagione per action si è conclusa
ebbene se io prendo la pausa estiva o
per meglio dire la pausa di agosto come
fine di una stagione di video e
quest'anno è finita la prima stagione
dello show e io non posso far altro che
ringraziare tutte le persone che hanno
seguito gli episodi questa mia prima
prova di una sorta di lecce che è
partita lentamente poi ha ingranato
perché sono riuscito ad acchiappare il
mio tipo di umorismo con questo tipo di
format e e sono riuscito a fare dei
video decenti e io di questo voglio
parlarvi in questo micro video estivo
dell'evoluzione che avrà da settembre
lecce e di come ho impostato io lo
studio perché voi non avete idea delle
condizioni in cui registro dunque come
ho detto portare il e ciò nel mio canale
era un azzardo era una prova per vedere
se fossi riuscito in qualche modo a
portare quel tipo di format
modificandolo ovviamente per youtube su
youtube e il risultato si può riassumere
in più o meno nel senso che i video sono
venuti fuori gli argomenti c'erano e
tecnicamente discreto ma la sensazione
che da sé che non è un vero e proprio
lecce perché il e ciò solo una scatola
in cui ci buttano dentro di tutto le
interviste le canzoni sketch comici
cortometraggi monologhi c'è di tutto
invece medi dove erano soltanto prendere
un argomento sviscerarlo il più
possibile in modo più o meno comico e
via e questo non dà spazio a nient'altro
per esempio se io voglio fare un
piccolissimo corto di un minuto su uno
scaldabagno per di per fare un esempio
non posso metterlo da nessuna parte se
sto parlando di profili ma con le idee
che ho in mente che adesso vi dico da
metà settembre possiamo trasformare il
leccio e farci il cazzo che ci pare il
cazzo che ci pare il cazzo che ci pare
peso sul
arcuri e carlo sulla barale quello che
avevo in mente era la prima stagione di
questo show non era proprio impostata
come uno show nel senso siccome io
chiamavo individuo del leccio trattino
titolo sembrava che il leccio forse
soltanto una piccola parentesi nel mio
canale fosse un format del mio canale lo
show in realtà io vorrei proprio
trasformare il canale in un leccio in
modo da poterci mettere dentro tutte le
cose che io avrei voluto continuare a
fare per esempio i pausa i cortissimi
perché non recensioni di film magari un
po più corte un po più piccoli in modo
da poterne fare di più anche le
interviste io volevo mettere nello so ma
non sapevo dove proprio per lo stesso
problema divideva perché se io avessi
voluto intervistare michelle obama per
esempio se io faccio il video del leccio
sulla realtà virtuale non è che cozza
benissimo insomma è oggi mentre lavavo
il mio corpo nudo sotto la doccia
mi è venuta all'illuminazione siccome io
voglio portare dell'intrattenimento a mo
di leisure
non devo chiamare i video vele ciò devo
chiamare in canale vele giocondo toby in
modo che già l'impostazione esterna sia
un leccio e poi video dentro facciano
solo parte di quella impostazione
mi congratulo con me stesso ovviamente
tenendo il nome di toby perché comunque
io così sono su you tube e quindi
chiamarlo del action con gli automi
e sapete cosa vuol dire questo che
finalmente potrò cambiare il mio cazzo
di avatar
sono letteralmente dieci anni che ce
l'ho io ho una foto dell'avatar in cui
sono minorenne e finalmente possiamo
impostare il canale come cazzo ci pare
pausa cortometraggi recensioni perché no
mi piacerebbe portarvi degli eventi che
possa essere un video da 20 minuti dove
farlo di gomorra per esempio oppure uno
sketch di un minuto e mezzo su un
argomento specifico
e siccome me l'avete chiesto in
tantissime ora vi faccio vedere qual è
la mia postazione di lavoro e quindi
farò una cosa che non ho mai fatto in
vita mia
promotur
e siccome non l'ho mai fatto dovrà un po
ispirarmi a chi è esperto in questo
settore
benvenuti nel mio rom tour mi raccomando
lasciato un pollicione perché se non
voglia di farlo dunque questa è la
postazione in cui di solito giro il
light
questo è lo sfondo sono due pannelli di
legno che nei video sembrano grigi ma in
realtà sono marrone scuro perché
l'illuminazione li rende grigi e quello
invece un trittico su tela di torino che
ho preso sul sito che stampa queste cose
qui che ho pagato un bel po ma la resa è
incredibile e pensare che c'era gente
che credeva fosse un green screen è uno
skyline di torino con dietro le montagne
e alcuni di voi mi hanno detto che le
montagne in realtà da lontano sembrano
un enorme tsunami che sta per
distruggere tutto la cosa buffa è che è
vero sembrano tsunami grazie per gli
incubi quello che io vedo davanti è
questo tralasciando quel quadro che non
so qui abbiamo due faretti con
l'ombrello che sono la mia illuminazione
e standard pagati si è con gli ombrelli
sia con il treppiede sia con le
lampadine entrambi 60 euro
e incredibile come così economiche non
mi siano ancora scoppiate in faccia e
che io sia ancora in vita
poi abbiamo un treppiede cinese pagato
10 euro e poi il dramma questo casino di
prese di cavi di portatili è dovuto alla
telecamera che sto usando siccome la sto
usando non riesco a farvela vedere è una
sony alpha 5.100 che ottima se devi fare
una cosa del genere e non hai nessun
operatore nessun cameraman che ti aiuti
con il fuoco manuale questa piccola
perla un fuoco automatico ottimo ma un
piccolissimo problema
dopo dieci minuti di registrazione
simultanea si surriscalda e si spegne ha
praticamente per poter registrare più di
dieci minuti perché più o meno una
registrazione a me prende un'oretta a 50
minuti un ora devo attaccare la sony
altre piede poi mi è venuto un idea ho
preso una scheda di acquisizione di da
console praticamente quella che usa nel
game player per registrare da console
punto collegare con tutti questi cavi al
portatile e alla telecamera di tutto
aprile programma di registrazione
registrare direttamente dal computer
quello che la telecamera vede e questa è
una delle due cose che mi ha salvato la
vita per lo show
l'altra e l'audio dove ho girato girato
in casa nei vecchi studi nei vecchi
uffici l'audio che rimbomba con soffitti
altissimi e riverberi vari porca tutta
la tua mamma mi perseguitava e non
riuscivo a metterla a posto sia con
microfoni esterni con microfoni interni
della tele cup
mi si è spenta la telecamera dicevo
l'audio è sempre stato il mio più grande
nemico e qui ho voluto prenderlo
d'anticipo ho comprato tipo 300 mila
pannelli fonoassorbenti e ciò riempito
tutte le pareti possibili compreso sotto
la scala la negli angoli non so se vi si
vede un po scuro il soffitto del
soppalco ma purtroppo non potendo bucare
qui ho messo gli adesivi che c'erano in
insieme ma purtroppo non reggono
devo ringraziare mio padre che mi ha
aiutato a mettere tutto questo insieme
abbiamo anche messo questa attenda molto
pesante per assorbire il suono
dall'altra parte invece c'è l'entrata
dell'ufficio che dà direttamente sulle
scale sul proprio il piano terra delle
scale quindi chi entra esce lo sento
come non mai grazie signora del secondo
piano che a quel bambino di merda che
prima o poi se lo becco gli entri
scivolate gli spezzoni tibia e
dall'altra parte come avete visto prima
c'è lo sfondo che però voi non avete
visto quanto è grande e piccolissimo
zoom o leggermente in più
leggermente più indietro si vede tutto
quello che c'è intorno però vedi
zoomando un pochino it's magic ma
nonostante tutti i pannelli audio non
era abbastanza del video di prima vi
faccio sentire un pezzo senza al
microfono che ho comprato ma soltanto
con il microfono della telecamera come
potete vedere sono completamente sfratto
dalla cravatta dovuta a sfasciare un
mezzo sveti agio senti il profumo di
professionalità nell'aria di yotobi come
fare come fare come fare la seconda
volta che mi è stata salvata la vita e
grazie assai di breaking italy perché
mentre piangevo non sapendo che cazzo
fare della mia vita con l'audio
ho guardato lui ho detto cavolo noi ha
la mia stessa praticamente impostazione
come sfondo e e siamo quasi alla stessa
distanza di telecamera cosa cazzo usa
per farsi sentire così bene oh mio dio
microfoni a clip o in termini
professionali il mali e adesso attaccato
male perché di solito lo attaccò la
giacca che non ho però questo è quella è
la seconda cosa che mi ha salvato la
vita
e questo è tutto io sono sempre più
dentro da solo a girare i video con i
pannelli fonoassorbenti che mi tengono
compagnia e torino che sta per essere
colpita da uno tsunami e il deodorante
vaniglia gelsomino per niente per oggi
era tutto mi raccomando se volete vedere
il prossimo episodio lasciate
centocinquantamila like perché se non li
raggiungiamo noi dobbiamo trovare un
lavoro vero io non so scrivere il
curriculum quindi per favore non
lasciatemi morire di fame mezzo alla
strada
lasciate passato una buona estate noi ci
rivediamo a metà settembre con la
seconda stagione dello show